this word Observer it means something in
quantum mechanics it means something
in a lot of places it means something to
us humans right as conscious beings so
what what's the importance of the
Observer what is the Observer and what's
the importance of the observer in the
computational universe so this question
of what is an observer what's the
general idea of an observer it's
actually one of my next projects which
got somewhat derailed by the the current
sort of AI Mania but um is there a
connection there or is that uh do you do
you think the Observer is primarily a
physics phenomena is it related to the
whole AI thing yes yes it is related so
one question is what is a general
Observer so you know we know we have an
idea what is a general computational
system we think about Turing machines we
think about other models of computation
there's a question what is a general
model of an observer and the there's
kind of observers like us which is kind
of The Observers we're interested in you
know we could imagine an alien Observer
that deals with computational
irreducibility and it has a mind that's
utterly different from ours and and
completely incoherent with what what
we're like but the fact is that that you
know if we are talking about observers
like us that one of the key things is
this idea of kind of taking all the
detail of the world and being able to
stuff it into a mind being able to take
all the detail and kind of you know
extract out of it a smaller set of of
kind of degrees of freedom a smaller
number of elements that will sort of fit
in our minds and I think this this
question so I've been interested in
trying to characterize what is the
general Observer and the general
Observer is I think in part there are
many let me give an example of a you
know you have a gas it's got a bunch of
molecules bouncing around and the thing
you're measuring about the gas is its
pressure and the only anything you as an
observer care about is pressure and that
means you have a piston on the side of
this box and the Piston is being pushed
by the gas and there are many many
different ways that molecules can hit
that piston but all that matters is the
kind of aggregate of all those molecular
impacts because that's what determines
pressure so there's a huge number of
different configurations of the gas
which are all equivalent so I think one
key aspect of observers is this
equivalency of many different
configurations of a system saying all I
care about is this aggregate feature all
I care about is this this overall thing
and that's that sort of one one aspect
and when we see that in lots of
different again it's the same story over
and over again that there's there's a
lot of detail in the world but what we
are extracting from it is something a
sort of a thin a thin summary of that of
that detail is that thin summary
nevertheless true is can it be a crappy
approximation sure that on average is is
correct I mean if we look at the observe
that's the human mind it seems like
there's a lot of very
um as represented by natural language
for example there's a lot of really
crappy approximation sure and that could
be maybe a feature of it well with this
ambiguity right right you don't know you
know it could be the case you're just
measuring the aggregate impacts of these
molecules but there is some tiny tiny
probability that molecules will arrange
themselves in some really funky way and
that just measuring that average isn't
going to the main point yeah by the way
an awful lot of science is very confused
about this because you know you look at
you look at papers and people are really
Keen they draw this curve and they have
these you know these bars on the curve
and things it's just this curve and it's
this one thing and it's supposed to
represent some system that has all kinds
of details in it and this is a way that
lots of science has gotten wrong because
people say I remember years ago I was
studying snowflake growth you know you
have a snowflake and it's growing it has
all these arms it's doing complicated
things but there was a literature on
this stuff and it talked about you know
what's the rate of snowflake growth and
you know it got pretty good answers for
the rate of the growth of the Snowflake
and they looked at it more carefully and
they had these nice curves of you know
snowflake growth rates and so on I
looked at it more carefully and I
realized according to their models the
snowflake will be spherical
and so they got the growth rate right
but the detail was just utterly wrong
and you know that not only the detail
that the whole thing was was not
capturing you know it was capturing this
aspect of the system that was in a sense
missing the main point of what was going
on and what is the geometric uh shape of
a snowflake snowflakes start in in the
phase of water that's relevant to
formation of snowflakes it's a phase of
ice but it starts with a hexagonal
arrangement of water molecules and so it
starts off growing as a hexagonal plate
and then what happens is is the plate oh
oh versus sphere sphere well no no but
it's it's much more than that I mean
snowflakes are fluffy you know typical
snowflakes have little little dendritic
arms yeah and what actually happens is
it's kind of kind of cool because you
can make these very simple discrete
models with cellular automata and things
that that figure this out you start off
with this you know hexagonal thing and
then the places it starts to grow little
arms and every time a little piece of
ice it adds itself to the snowflake the
fact that that ice condensed from the
water vapor heats the snowflake up
locally and so it makes it less likely
for uh for another piece of ice to
accumulate right nearby so this leads to
a kind of growth inhibition so you grow
an arm and it is a separated arm because
right around the arm it got a little bit
hot and it didn't add more ice there so
what happens is it grows you have a
hexagon it grows out arms the arms go
arms and then the arms go arms go arms
and eventually actually it's kind of
cool because it actually fills in
another hexagon a bigger hexagon and
when I first looked at this we had a
very simple model for this I realized
you know when it fills in that hexagon
it actually leaves some holes behind so
I thought well you know that is that
really right so look at these pictures
of snowflakes and sure enough they have
these little holes in them that are kind
of scars of the way that these arms grow
out
um so you can't fill in backfill holes
yeah they don't backfill and presumably
there's a limitation of how big like you
can't arbitrarily grow
I'm not sure I mean the thing falls
through the the I mean I think it just
you know it hits the ground at some
point I think you can grow I think you
can grow in the lab I think you can grow
pretty big ones I think you can grow
many many iterations of this kind of
goes from hexagon it grows out arms it
turns back it fills back into a hexagon
it grows more arms again in 3D no it's
flat usually why is it flat why doesn't
it uh span out okay wait a minute you
said it's fluffy and fluffy is a
three-dimensional property no or no it's
it's fluffy snow is okay so you know
what makes we're really uh we're really
in it but there's multiple snowflakes
become fluffy a single snowflake is not
fluffy no no single snowflake is Fluffy
and what happens is you know if if you
have snow that it's just pure hexagons
they they can you know they they fit
together pretty well it's not it doesn't
it doesn't make it doesn't have a lot of
air in it and they can also slide
against each other pretty easily and so
the snow can be pretty you know can I
think avalanches happen sometimes when
when the things tend to be these you
know hexagonal plates and it kind of
slides but then when the thing has all
these arms that have grown out it's not
they don't fit together very well and
that's why the snow has lots of air in
it and if you look at one of these
snowflakes and if you catch one you'll
see it has these little arms and people
actually people often say you know no
two snowflakes are alike
um that's mostly because as a snowflake
grows they do grow pretty consistently
with these different arms and so on but
you capture them at different times as
they you know they fell through through
the air in a different way you'll catch
this one at this stage and as it goes
through different stages they look
really different and so that's why you
know kind of looks like no two slime
flakes are alike because you caught them
at different at different times so the
rules under which they grow are the same
it's just the timing is yes okay so the
point is science is not able to uh
describe the full complexity of
snowflake growth well science if you if
you do what people might often do just
say okay let's make it scientific let's
turn into one number and that one number
is kind of the growth rate of the arms
or some such other thing that fails to
capture sort of the detail of what's
going on inside the system and that's in
a sense a big challenge for science is
how do you extract from the natural
world for example those aspects of it
that you are interested in talking about
now you might just say I don't really
care about the fluffiness of the
snowflakes all I care about is the
growth rate of the arms in which case
you know you have you can have a good
model without knowing anything about the
fluffiness
um but the fact is as a practical you
know when if you if you say what's the
what is the most obvious feature of a
snowflake oh that it has this
complicated shape well then you've got a
different story about what you model I
mean this is one of the features of sort
of modeling and science that you know
what is a Model A model is some way of
reducing the actuality of the world to
something where you can readily sort of
give a narrative for what's happening
where you can basically make some kind
of abstraction of what's happening and
answer questions that you care about
answering if you want to answer all
possible questions about the system
you'd have to have the whole system
because you might care about this
particular molecule where did it go and
you know your model which is some big
abstraction of that has nothing to say
about that so you know one of the things
that's that's often confusing in science
is people will have I've got a model
somebody says somebody else will say I
don't believe in your model because it
doesn't capture the feature of the
system that I care about you know
there's always this controversy about
you know is the is it a correct model
well no model is a except for the actual
system itself is a correct model in the
sense that it captures everything
questions does It capture what you care
about capturing sometimes that's
ultimately defined by what you're going
to build technology out of things like
this the one counter example to this is
if you think you're modeling the whole
universe all the way down then there is
a notion of a correct model but even
that is more complicated because it
depends on kind of how observers sample
things and so on that's a that's a
separate story but at least at the first
level to say you know this thing about
oh it's an approximation you're
capturing one aspect you're not
capturing other aspects when you really
think you have a complete model for the
whole universe you better be capturing
ultimately everything even though oh to
actually run that model is impossible
because of computational reducibility
the only the only thing that
successfully runs that model is the
actual running of the universe is the
universe itself but okay so what you
care about
is an interesting concept so that's a
that's a human concept so that's what
you're doing with uh wolf from Alpha and
Wolfram language is you trying to come
up with symbolic representations yes as
simple as possible
uh so a model that's as simple as
possible that fully captures stuff we
care about yes so I mean for example you
know we could we'll have a thing about
you know data about movies let's say we
could be describing every individual
pixel in every movie and so on but
that's not the level that people care
about and it's yes this is a I mean and
and that level that people care about is
somewhat related to what's described in
natural language but what what we're
trying to do is to find a way to sort of
represent precisely so you can compute
things see see one thing when you say
you give a piece of natural language
question is you feed it to a computer
you say does the computer understand
this natural language
well you know the computer process it in
some way it does this maybe it can make
a continuation of the natural language
you know maybe it can go on from The
Prompt and say what it's going to say
you say does it really understand it
hard to know but for in this kind of
computational world there is a very
definite definition of does it
understand which is could it be turned
into this symbolic computational thing
from which you can compute all kinds of
consequences and that's the that's the
sense in which one has sort of a target
for the understanding of natural
language and that's kind of our goal is
to have as much as possible about the
world that can be computed in a in a
reasonable way so to speak be able to be
sort of captured by this kind of
computational language that's that's
kind of the goal and and I think for us
humans the the main thing that's
important is as we formalize what we're
talking about it gives us a way of kind
of building a structure where we can
sort of build this Tower of consequences
of things so if we're just saying well
let's talk about it in natural language
it doesn't really give us some hard
Foundation that lets us you know build
step by step to work something out I
mean it's kind of like what happens in
math if we were just sort of vaguely
talking about math but didn't have the
kind of full structure of math and all
that kind of thing we wouldn't be able
to build this kind of big tower of
consequences and so you know in a sense
what we're trying to do with the whole
computational language effort is to make
a formalism for describing the world
that makes it possible to kind of build
this this Tower of consequences